Ron DeSantis has signed a six-week
abortion ban ended concealed weapons
permits the requirement for such permits
ban gender affirming care for Trans
youth restricted drag shows expanded the
don't say gay law blocked and uh an
advanced placement African-American
studies curriculum class and prohibited
vaccine mandates I am going to make two
arguments to you here first argument all
of these bills and laws are terrible
ideas and number two many of them also
directly contradict the stated values of
low government intervention little
government involvement freedom and
liberty that they claim to espouse